Hah dah deh lah loWOOOAAHGOTCHYOU! aauh
You win this round!
MOO! MOO, MOO, MOO,
A-MOO-Y
YOU ARE MY BEST FRIEND! WE WILL GO FOR WALKIES-
Dog: oh...
Dog: euh Cow: AND WE WILL GO ON A PICINIC Dog:ewh Cow:AND WE WILL HAVE SO MUCH FUN!! FOREVER! AND EVER!
AND EVER! Dog: PLEASE STOP!
MOO? *disgusted* oh...
HAHAHA, AH-AGH, MOO! AHAH, AGH-AGH MOO!
MOOO! *other cow joins in* MOO!
AH! WHO ARE YOU!? OHH, EEUUGH!
AAUGH, IT'S SO F**KING COLD! GAWD!
A-MOO! AH MOO! AGH MOO!
UH... DAD I DUNNO ABOUT THIS! CowDad: YOU'RE DOIN' GREAT SON!
MOOO-OW! I'M FREEZING MY UDDERS OFF!!
eeuuuEEHH MOO B*TCH! CowDad: THAT'S MAH BOYY!
ITS STILL COLD! *random cow noises* Cow: OH GOD, SHUT UP!
MOOOOO!
THIS TAIL IS MINE AND IT'S MINE AND IT'S MINE FOREVER! ITS
MINE Cow: could you not? Dog: EEUUGHH... WOOF WOOF! WOOF!
Cow: okay fine.
What if I told you that this video was one big Markimoo joke? Cow in background: NOOOOOO